Peter King NBC sports.com NFL columnist
check out his column must reading
football morning in America every Monday
exclusively on NBC sports.com good
morning Pete how are you hey Dan you
know that's very very interesting what
you say about Rudy I mean because
everybody asked me all the time hey
what's your favorite team yeah and I say
well I root for the Red Sox because I
don't cover baseball but they say okay
yeah yeah but what about what about
football and I said uh I haven't rooted
for football teams since I you know
started covering the Bengals for the
Cincinnati Enquirer and and it just and
people are always shocked at that what
do you mean you don't root and I said
how can you ruin my number the sport but
but it makes it easier for me because
I'm rooting for a story I just want the
story that's the whole thing yeah yeah I
always somebody says to me like when I
was a kid I was a Jacobin Connecticut
and I was a Giants fan in football my
dad was a big Giants fan and all that
and so now if the Giants are playing
anybody who ever it doesn't matter the
only thing I care about it's the story I
mean you know I could care less if they
want I just just like but can I get I
got to tell you a very very quick story
Minnesota Vikings against the Green Bay
Packers at the old Metrodome once I'm
covering the game Vikings win I forget
the circumstances but it was a
heartbreaking loss for the Packers and I
go in afterwards in those days you know
Sports Illustrated shows up it's a big
game and and so I go in to see Mike
Holmgren and he's like really down and
at one point during the course of the
conversation he just looks at me and he
goes you don't care do you know like
about his pain and it was sort of a
wistful was i angry thing and I just
said no I don't how can I care like what
do you want me to care if Danny Green
wins or Mike Holmgren how can I do that
I can't do that anyway well I like I
care about your pain if it helps me with
my story
Yeah right I mean that's that's what it
comes down to I still go back and I tell
people you know the Mets and the Red Sox
when the ball goes through Buckner's
legs and I it didn't matter who won you
know you know I was probably rooting a
little bit more for the Red Sox because
of the story but that crazy Mets team
was so fun to cover and I'm sitting
there watching Bill Buckner answer all
of these questions after letting the
ball go through his legs and I couldn't
help but feel sorry but then I was also
happy that you know I had a story but
the story was Bill Buckner and and so
you you just extract that out of these
games and you sort of leave everything
else you know to the wayside here but it
makes it easier if I said I'm a Bengals
fan
and you're a Steeler fan and I go on
SportsCenter I report on the Steelers
then you go he's a Bengal phone so you
course you know you can't do all hey
look and it won't matter it won't matter
what I say or what you say everybody's
going to think what they think like you
know the whole free world thinks oh my
god he's in the tank for the Patriots he
loves the Patriots there's absolutely
nothing I can do to either disprove or
say anything people are just gonna think
what they're gonna think so that's
that's just the way life is yeah I know
boohoo nobody's you know having sympathy
if you could if you could write the
story of Kyler Murray on draft day like
where he goes the best story would be
what for the NFL and Kyler Murray the
best story in my opinion would be if Jon
Gruden found a way to take him and then
he had to find a way in the middle of
the first round to dump you know to dump
Derek Carr somewhere okay let's say the
Giants maybe or or Miami I don't know
what pick a team maybe even Washington
who knows but that would be the best
story because it would create the most
mayhem I think most people now there's
not enough attachment of any sort other
than sort of chortle at charlie Casserly
there's not enough attachment of any
sort about Kyler Murray and Josh Rosen
and the Arizona Cardinal
it's sort of what everybody thinks is a
60% chance of happening so but the fun
thing would be if Gruden said I gotta
have this guy I gotta have my flavor of
the month
and then he had to try to find a market
for four Derek Carr in 15 minutes now
that would be fun all right
Le'Veon Bell I it feels like we're not
as interested where he's going as to how
much he's going to make because he left
15 million so really how many teams do
you think are truly involved and is
Le'Veon Bell gonna make up for what he
left on the table I'll tell you why I
think this is taking so long and I might
be wrong about this okay but I'll tell
you why I think it's taken so long I
think this is just my gut feeling
I think Le'Veon Bell is really trying to
you know to basically play all of these
teams that are interested in him like
Chicago like Baltimore like the Raiders
like the Jets who everybody thought
including me that he would sign with
yeah but but I think one of the reasons
right now is that he is trying to
because he's got to get a contract
that's going to pay him I mean it's not
if he's the highest-paid running back in
football I think everybody sort of
expects that that's going to happen
that's not a very high bar that's like
the highest-paid guard you know it's
just not a very high bar right now so
and and and I believe if this is just my
absolute gut feeling that Le'Veon Bell
would like to sign with Baltimore and I
just wrote on Twitter a while ago I do I
will be shocked if the Ravens are the
highest bidder it's just not their way
their way would be to say to levy on
bail and his agent they look we would
love to have you but we're not gonna be
we're not going to chase the money here
look at our history in free agency we
don't overpay they wanted CJ Moseley
back but maybe at 12 or 13 not at 17 or
whatever it is he
and they wanted they want to keep a lot
of their guys they wanted to have sons
back but macat the end of the day the
Ravens are a lot more there the
franchise that is most similar in free
agency to the Patriots who were the Jags
negotiating against for Nick Foles I
really don't think anybody but I think
that this was Nick Foles and his agent
basically saying look you know whatever
whatever this whatever it seems you know
all were asking to be with this contract
is and I'm gonna I'm gonna estimate it
to be the 13th highest paid quarterback
in football that's what we're asking and
you know what we're gonna be clipped by
four or five more quarterbacks in the
next next year so he's not even going to
be among the the the top half paid
quarterbacks in the NFL so in my opinion
pardon the dog Dan but in my opinion I
think that everything right are you are
you in Cleveland and yeah I mean who let
the dog out okay let's let's hold on
Pete let's let's guess go ahead let's
guess Peter Kings dog I have to recuse
myself I just heard him yell the dog's
name no no not his name or the the breed
Paulie no a boxer okay
seat nope say a basset hound basset
hound
no no what he is he's about he's about a
75 percent golden retriever and then
he's got a bunch of other things like
Weimaraner than just a bunch of other
mongrel Tice's no that's who he is
name is Johnny gets he gets excited when
the groceries come in his name is Chuck
yeah what do you think of that name it's
not a great name for a dog I wanted to
name my dog peeve why my pet peeve
I thought your naming him after Jake
Peavy oh no no you didn't have that good
a career but you know here you are going
back to your Red Sox fandom there with
Jake Peavy I love me the one who bought
the duck pie yes yeah yeah yeah I love
the the chief signing of Tyrann Mathieu
I thought it was sneaky good I don't
know what you thought about that or any
other ones that you thought were really
good that stood out I mean you know what
you know what stands out to me right now
like like if you look at the teams that
have signed safeties now washing most
notably Washington Kansas City Houston
with patient Gibson and Chicago with
Adrian Amos
today you know what that says to me that
Earl Thomas played his market too high
and you know Earl Thomas ought to be
signed right now and and I think I think
Earl Thomas ends up in a place maybe
Dallas I don't know
but Earl Thomas ends up in a place for
less money than he thought he was gonna
make yeah the whole safety thing is
interesting and washing I don't know
what Washington's doing I mean Landon
Collins is a nice player but if the
Giants are letting him walk Washington
takes him feels like they got other
things to worry about there and here's
the thing about Washington you know look
at the teams that have spent a jillion
dollars right now okay they're all teams
that were below 500 didn't make the
playoffs and have a quasi desperate
reason to be spending money Green Bay
you know Aaron Rodgers 35 years old how
many more years do you have of Aaron
Rodgers in his prime you've got to try
to get a decent defense with with a
couple of edge rushers so that you have
a chance
that's one team the Jets you know the
Jets have been chasing the Patriots for
all of Tom Brady's career once or twice
they've caught him but they've never
passed them and then Washington I mean
look at look look at the problems right
now the Dan Snyder has it he's trying to
get a new stadium built to replace a
stadium that is not
obsolete he's got fans who are
abandoning his team in droves and so
these teams this is what the NFLPA you
know has a parade about every year they
know that there are going to be
desperate teams who are going to spend
money like they've got holes Britt like
like money is burning a hole in their
pocket the smart teams and I count
Indianapolis among them look at
Indianapolis they got a hundred million
dollars to spend under the cap and
they're not spending any of it they've
spent ten million dollars so far on one
player that's it and they're not going
to start spending until the silly money
stops so it's just it happens every year
it happens every year and I just want to
know if the teams that that spent giant
on like look at the Giants last year
spending all that money on Nate's older
I mean are they happy right now you know
with Nate's older you know until
yesterday being the highest paid
defensive tackle in the game hey you
know so and you know what the Raiders I
forgot to include them the Raiders you
know they've got to do the exact same
thing they've got to show the people in
Vegas that we're going to bring a good
team to Vegas next year so I just think
that rules so many decisions at these
times at this time of year
not necessarily let's try to have a
winning franchise for the next five
years Pete good to talk to you tell
Chuck we said goodbye as well was he
named after Chuck Noll
no he's just named because I thought
Chuck was a great name for a dog you
know and plus it's easy to get him to
respond like if he's doing some bad just
like Chuck you know I mean it's just a
one syllable yeah it's easy you know
anyway thank you Peter all right that's
know Dan this Peter King NBC sports.com
the NFL columnist for more Dan Patrick
show to the audio
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]